ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโอเคกลับมาเจอกับครัว
ตี้หลวงพี่เอ๋ฮ่าๆในช่องคอม preemptive
ไทย
กูเอาตี้คะ
สบายดีไหมคะ
จะถามวันต่อเลยไม่เคยถามสบายดีไหมสบายดี
ดีสบายดียังแข็งแรงยังแข็งแรงอยู่อู่
พี่สบายดีใช่ไหมครับกินข้าวหรือยังอิ่ม
แล้วค่ะเพราะอิ่มแล้วใช่มั้ยอีกแล้ววัน
นี้อิ่มแล้วเหมือนกันพี่ก็อิ่มแล้วนะคะ
ให้มีแรงมีแรงที่อิ่มแล้วเนี่ยพูดได้นั่น
น่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
มีแรงหิวหิว
มีคนไทยคนไทยเวลาเจอกันส่วนใหญ่คนไทยก็จะ
ถามว่ากินข้าวหรือยังกินข้าว
สบายดีไว้นี่ก็กินภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะเนาะได้
อ่านิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยส่วนใหญ่กินข้าวหรือ
ยังถ้ากินข้าวหรือยังไปไหนไปไหนมาเนี่ยจะ
ถามว่าแล้ววันนี้วันอะไรคะค่ะอาจารย์วัน
นี้ใช่ไหมครับโอเควันนี้วัน
นี้วันจันทร์ครับผมวันจันทร์แล้ววัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันจันทร์
ที่ 13 ครับ
13  5 อะไรคะวิฑูรย์ายนนเคเดือนมิถุนายน
พ.ศ
2565 ครับถ้าแล้วปีคศอะไรคะพ.ศ 2020  2
ปีนี้ 22 ใช่ครับอ่ะและแล้ววันนี้ขวดตี้
10 นี้วันนี้คลิปนี้กดหากตอนนี้พานัก
เรียนไปเที่ยวจังหวัดอะไรคะอ้าคลิปนี้ใช่
ไหมครับจะพาไปเที่ยวจังหวัดปราจีนบุรี
ครับแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยกว่านี้ที่เราอัด
วีดีโอกันเนี่ยราะอะเวลาสอนกริ่ง 7:00 น
7:00  25 นาทีนลืมถามเวลาจะไปเที่ยว
อย่างเดียวเลยวันนี้อื่น
25 นาทีอ่ะโอเคอ่ะไปครับไปเที่ยวพร้อม
แล้ว
ไปกันครับ
แต่ไม่ได้ไปตอนนี้นะกลัวเตี้ยไปมาแล้วนะ
ก็จะเล่าให้นักเรียนตอนนี้แหละไปที่
จังหวัดจังหวัดหนึ่ง 5 จังหวัดปราจีนบุรี
ครับ
ปราจีนบุรีนี้อยู่ไกลจากกรุงเทพมากก็หา
อยู่ไกลไม่มากครับประมาณ
120 กิโลกรัมประมาณ
ไกลจากกรุงเทพฯ 120 กิโลเมตรใช่ครับ
ประมาณกับกรุงเทพฯอยู่ตรงนี้
ปาร์ตีนบุรีสีอยู่ตรงนี้
ปาร์ตี้บุรีสีเขียว
อ่านี่ครับเดี๋ยวกลัวที่ขยาย
5 นี่ปราจีนบุรีสีเขียวก็สีม่วงจังหวัด
อะไรอ่ะดีนอนสระแก้วใช่ครับเดี๋ยวเมื่อ
ก่อนเป็นจังหวัดเดียวกันใช่ไหม
ครูเอ๋น่ะคู๋นะจำว่าปราจีนบุรีคือติด
กัมพูชาขอใจขับเขาเพิ่มก็เพิ่มจังหวัด
สระแก้วมาแต่ก็เข้ามาเป็น 10 ปีเลยใกล้ๆ
กับพี่นะจ๊ะไม่เคยไปปราจีนไงอ่อๆเลยจำว่า
ปราจีนสระแก้วเป็นจังหวัดเดียวกันออกไม่
ใช่นะคะในอาหารเมื่อก่อนจังหวัดเดียวกัน
มีแต่ว่าแบ่งแบ่งได้ครับแบ่งเป็นสอง
จังหวัดแบ่งเป็นปราจีนบุรีกับสระแก้วแยก
กันตะแคนะคะปฏิทินบุหรี่ก็จะติดกับ
นครราชสีมาหรือติดกับโคราชที่เราเคยไปกัน
แล้วก็ติดกับสระแก้วได้ครับ
ไม่เคยไปทั้งสระแก้วแล้วก็ปราจีนขอ
พี่เอ๋กับนักเรียนไปเที่ยวไปครับไปพระจีน
กันเดี๋ยวเราไปดูกันว่าที่พาจีนเนี่ยมี
ที่ไหนที่น่าสนใจมากนะครับครูอาร์ทตี้ไป
มานานหรือยังคะอ้าไปมาน่ารักครับน่ารัก
ครับน่าเคยไปเดี๋ยวนะแต่ก็ไปหลายครั้ง
ครับไปอาจจะปีที่แล้วก็ไปหากมีขับรถผ่าน
ไปแล้วก็แวะนิดนึงอะไรอย่างนี้ใช่ครับ
เป็นคนชอบเที่ยวปราจีนนะคะ
ไปหลายทั้งวันครับแล้วก็ไปรับผ่านแล้วก็
แวะข้างนึงเขาก็ไปที่อื่นเขาก็แวะอีกที
นึงอะไรก็แวะได้บ่อยๆค่ะดีค่ะดีไม่ต้อง
อยู่นานที่ปฏิก็อยู่ใกล้ไปว่าอะไรก็ได้
ครับอยู่ใกล้กรุงเทพฯขับรถประมาณประมาณ 1
ชั่วโมงครึ่ง 2 ชั่วโมงก็ถึงแล้วนะครับ
งั้นไปดูไอ้นี่นะครับที่แรกที่จะพาไปเอา
เป็นที่ที่เอ่อคนไทยหลายๆคนรู้จักนัก
เรียนอาจจะรู้จักที่นี่ก็ได้ครับที่นี่
ครับสวยจังอ่าที่นี่เป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์
พิพิธภัณฑ์ชื่อว่าพิพิธภัณฑ์เจ้าพระยา
อภัยภูเบศรหน้าพี่เอกเคยได้ยินชื่อนี้ไหม
ครับเคยได้ยินค่ะฮ่าๆทรายทรายเอกคิดถึง
โรงพยาบาล
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนนานมาแล้วนานมาแล้วตอน
ที่สร้างทิพย์ปีที่สร้างบ้านหลังนี้สร้าง
สำหรับเป็นที่ที่พักของในหลวงรัชกาลที่ ๔
๕ พระราชาคนที่ 4 ของประเทศไทยของ
กรุงเทพฯนะคะๆครับอ่าพระจอมเกล้าๆครับตอน
9 หา
และแล้วก็เดี๋ยวและเขาชื่ออะไรนะเอาพญา
เจ้ายาอภัยภูเบศ
ครับแล้วตอนนี้เป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์ใช่ไหมคะได้
ตอนนี้เป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์ครับเพราะว่านานมา
แล้ว
รักข้างในมีอะไรข้างในตอนนี้พี่นะพันธุ์
นี้เขาจะทำเกี่ยวกับอะพัฒนาสูตรยาสมุนไพร
ของไทยก็ได้ครับถ้าพูดถึงยาก็คือเวลาไม่
สบายใช่ไหมนายครับสบายเราต้องกินยา
แต่ปกติปวดหัวก็กินพาราเซตามอล
ก็กินพาราเซตามอลปวดฟัน
แต่คนไทยเมื่อก่อนไม่ได้กินยาพาราเซตาม
ออกไซด์เมื่อก่อนยังไม่มียังไม่มียาพารา
ในประเทศไทยเรากินยาสงวน I สะอาดยา
สมุนไพรอ่ะกูอติ
ยาสมุนไพรก็ทำมาจากต้นไม้ทำมาจากพืชทำมา
จากผลไม้นานแต่ว่าก็มีนะอ้าใช่ครับมาจาก
ดอกไม้ก็มีใช้ค่ะอาหารก็อะที่นี่ค่ะครับ
ที่ที่ศูนย์ยุทธภัณฑ์เจ้าพระยาอภัยภูเบศร
เขาก็มีคนที่มีความรู้เรื่องสมุนไพรใน
เยอะแล้วก็เอาสมุนไพรมา
ร่วมกันทำเป็นยาใช่ครับทำเป็นยาแก้ปวดหัว
โอ๊ยปวดท้องจ่ายหลายๆอย่างค่ะครูเอกก็กิน
ค่ะของอภัยภูเบศรอ๋อกูอีกกินกินสมุนไพร
อะไรจากวันนั้นน่ะเขาไม่ทันล่ะค่ะสี
เหลืองอ๋ออ๋อนี่ใช่ไหมครับมาขมิ้นชันอะไร
ตัว R ตี้มาก่อน
แกะขมิ้นชันน่ะกินประจำหน้าที่บ้านและ
ครัวติ
ตัวนี้จะดีสำหรับท้องหนอสำหรับไม่ปวดท้อง
พอดีสำหรับผู้หญิง / กับป้องกันโรคมะเร็ง
หนอ
ลงมะเร็งมะเร็งมันจะมีที่ผิวที่ผิวหนัง
ใช่ไหมค่ะเนี่ยผิวหนังถ้าเราไปอาบแดดร้อน
1 ช้อนแล้วไม่มีครีมกันแดดแบบนานๆน่ะก็
จะเป็นมะเร็งได้แบบผู้หญิงน่าจะมีวันเล็ง
จะเพาะก็ต้องกินขมิ้นชัน
ro69 สำหรับผู้หญิง
คนไทยคนไทยส่วนใหญ่ก็จะคุ้นเคยแล้วก็รู้
จักสมุนไพรดีแล้วก็กินยาสมุนไพรกันการ
ทั่วไปหลายๆคนก็กินกันขาย
ก็ถ้านักเรียนแบบไม่รู้จักใช่ไหมคะเอ้ย
สมุนไพรอะไรกินดีไม่ดีถ้านักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยต่อไปที่อ่ะอ่าใช่ครับพี่พัน
เจ้าพระยาอภัยภูเบศรชื่อยาวนะครับคืออยาก
แต่ก็จะมีสมุนไพรที่อยู่ในกล่องแล้วนะคะ
ถ้าใช่ครับขายก็จะเขียนว่าอภัยภูเบศรอัน
นี้ขายไปต่างประเทศด้วยนะใช่ขายไปต่าง
ประเทศด้วยไหมครับถ้ามีเป็นสมุนไพรที่
เป็นยาแล้วก็มีที่เป็นเครื่องสำอางด้วย
ทรายครับ 555
ที่แรกที่อภิภว่าเจ้าพระยาอภัยภูเบศรครับ
ลบไปต่อที่พิพิธภัณฑ์อีกทีนึงครับ
พิพิธภัณฑ์อะไรคะถ้าเป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์ที่
เอ่อเก็บเกี่ยวกับข้าวของของใช้ต่างๆที่
สมัยโบราณนานมาแล้วนานแล้วให้ทำให้โบราณ
ได้กี่ปี
บ่
ท่าสิบปีที่แล้วนี่โบราณไว้ฮะปีที่แล้ว
ยังไม่โบราณครับ 10 ปีที่แล้วนี่ปัจจุบัน
ยังใช้งานได้อยู่อาจจะยังใช้ได้อยู่อ่ะ
แต่มีของใช้บางอย่างที่บางทีเราก็ไม่ได้
ใช้แล้วสมัยนี้ไม่ได้ใช้แล้ว
หน้าก็ที่นี่ก็จะมีเก็บไว้ที่นี่ชื่อ
พิพิธภัณฑ์อยู่สุขสุวรรณ์
5 อยู่สุขสุวรรณ์หาชื่อถักชายใช้เป็น
อะไรห้อยหิวข้างบนน่ะข้างบนนี้ครับที่นี่
เนี่ยเป็นมีวิธีเก็บตะเกียงไว้เยอะมากมี
ประมาณประมาณ 10,000 ดวงนะมีเยอะมากรวบ
รวมเกี่ยวกับตะเกียงงาน
ตะเกียงตะเกียงส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นตะเกียงเจ้า
พายุ
[เพลง]
ตะเกียงเจ้าพายุเห็นรู้จักไหมตักเองเจ้า
ติวเวลาครูเอเด็กๆใช้ฮะจอร์จตายก่อนขวด E
เป็นเป็นเด็กควยตี้ก็เคยใช้ตะเกียงเจ้า
พายุ
รุ่นเดียวกันเหรอคะแต่แต่รุ่นนี้ตอนนี้
พี่คิดว่านักเรียนน่าจะไม่ได้ใช้แล้ว
อ่าแล้วคนส่วนใหญ่ก็ไม่ได้ใช้แล้วคนที่
อยู่ในเมืองนะกลัวที่เคยเห็นที่อยู่ต่าง
จังหวัดก็มีบางคนที่ยังใช้อยู่ใช่ๆเพราะ
ว่าต่างจังหวัดตอนนี้มีไฟฟ้าแต่มันทีม
เวลามีพายุอายุมีลมแล้วก็มีฝนข้าวน่ะค่ะ
ลดระดับราคาเขาก็ต้องมีตะเกียงนะคะเจ้า
พายุตะเกียงเจ้าพายุที่สว่างมากนะใช่ป่ะ
กินเจ้าพายุสว่างมากมันไฟไฟอันนี้ค่ะนัก
เรียนมันไฟมีออกอุ้ย
ไปออน่ะ
จะสว่างมากนะคะ
ตะเกียงเจ้าพายุทำไมถึงเรียกเตียงเจ้า
พยุงอ่า
ไม่มีเสียงไหม
อะตีคู๋เนี่ยเห็นอันนี้ตอนกูอายุ 7 ปีนะ
คะคือจะเจ็บและความเชื่อ 7 ปีขวบ 7 ขวบ 8
ขวด 9 ขวบและประมาณเนี้ยอ่ะอ่ะถ้าสิบขวบ
น่าจะเริ่มมีใฝ่
นะเนี่ยก็คือประมาณ 40 ปีที่แล้ว 40 ปี
แล้วสิ 44-4
เกิดหรือยังครู Arty  44 ปีที่แล้ว 4  44
ปิดเกิดแล้วครับแต่ตอนนั้นกลัวติ๊กจะ 1
ขวบกับ
พี่อายุเท่าไหร่
เพื่อนที่อยู่เท่าไหร่ที่ 14  +  1  45
ปีแล้วหรอ 15 แล้วหรอไปกับพี่เอกจะมาตี 39
ขอบคุณครับตัวตี้ดูเหมือนรู้เหมือน 39
ใช่ไหมทำไมกูเอ๋จำไม่ได้โอเคโอเคที่มึง
ชื่อว่าตะเกียงเจ้าพายุเพราะว่าตะเกียง
เนี้ยไม่กลัวลมแอบต่อให้ลมพายุพัดแรงเท่า
ไหร่จะเก่งนี้ก็สู้ได้ก็ยังไม่ดับเหรอคะ
ให้ไม่ดาบครับไม่เดาทำไมไม่ดับล่ะเพราะ
ว่าเขาว่ามีมีกระจกรอบๆใช่อ้ามีคมอยู่รอบ
ลมพัดลมพายุพัดเข้าไปข้างไหนไม่ได้ขอ
ขอบคุณค่ะคู๋นะแต่ว่าเพราะว่าเวลาเป็น
เกรงอันนี้เวลาจะจุดเนี่ยข้างล่างเป็น
แอลกอฮอล์หรือน้ำมันน่าเป็นน้ำมันก๊าดอ๋อ
ต้องถามมากเขาต้องให้แล้วก็ปั๊มลมเข้าไป
ตรงสีแดงๆตรงนี้ครับก็ปั๊มลมก็ไปกดตึกจะ
อัดลมเข้าไปค่ะแล้วแล้วมีไส้ใช่ไหมตรง
กลางจะมีไส้ใช่ครับมีใต้มีไส้ตรงที่เป็น
กระจกนะคะไงครับอยู่ข้างในเนี่ยครับข้าง
หลังก็จะสว่างจากตรงนั้นนายสว่าง
เข้าใจว่าที่ชื่อจะกางเกงเจ้าพายุพวกมี
เสียงมีเสียงด้วยมีเสียงด้วยครับ
น่าจะมีเสียงเพราะว่าตอนที่เราปั๊มลมมัน
ก็จะมีลมเข้าไปแล้วก็ดันน้ำมันที่อยู่
ข้างล่างนี้ขึ้นไปข้างบนแล้วก็คนน้ำมัน
หรอกน่ะแล้วไฟก็ติพรุ่งนี้
ทราย
เข้าใจละกูเอกก็มีมาตั้งนานว่าเอ๊ยเราทำ
เพราะว่าไส้จะรออยู่ข้างบนเนาะใช่ครับไส้
อยู่ข้างบนตรงนี้กลมลงมาไม่โดนพื้นข้าง
ล่างนะจริงๆแล้วก็เลยสงสัยว่าทำไมสว่าง
ได้อ่ะ
โอเคตะเกียงเจ้าพายุจะสว่างกว่าเตียงปกติ
มากประมาณ 6 เท่าค่ะอ้าว
ใช่ครับอ่าโอเคที่พิพิธภัณฑ์พิพิธภัณฑ์
อยู่สุขสุวรรณ์ก็จะเก็บกางเกงเจ้าพระยา
อายุเยอะมากที่นี่เราก็สามารถไปเดินดู
เดินดูตะเกียงหน้าตาแปลกๆๆ
ที่เราไม่เคยเห็นก็มีก็มาไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยฮะ
เลือกมาไม่ได้ครับเขาไม่ขายไม่ขายเขาเก็บ
ไว้เก็บไว้ให้คนเวลาที่ 5 อยากจะรู้ว่า
ตะเกียงสมัยโบราณหน้าตาเป็นแบบไหนก็ไปดู
ที่นี่คือเขาไม่ขายแต่ถ้าเรามีตะเกียงจะ
เอามากๆครับเราไม่อยากเก็บเราเอาไปให้ได้
ได้เอาไปให้เขาเก็บให้อ่ะได้ครับ
เดี๋ยวพาไปต่อครับไปพิพิธภัณฑ์มา 2 ที่
เข้ากับคู่ anal ร้อนนะครับเปิด
พี่ก็เปิดแอร์เหมือนกันบ้านครัวนี่ก็
ร้อนเหมือนกันนะครับ
โอเคมีพิพิธภัณฑ์เจ้าพระยา
อภัยภูเบศรกระพัน
อยู่สุขสุวรรณ์อยู่สุขศวัน
[เพลง]
นอนทำหามอันนี้เข้าฟรีหรือว่าเสียเงินอ่ะ
หน้าเสียเงินนับเสียเงินนิดหน่อยไม่แพง
ครับประมาณ 20 บาท
ค่ะได้ครับไม่แพงเป็นค่าดูแลพิพิธภัณฑ์
นิดหน่อยๆค่ะแล้วของเจ้าเจ้าพระยา
อภัยภูเบศรอ่ะค่ะอ่าเจ้าพระยาอภัยภูเบศร
เข้าไปได้เลยครับเพราะว่าเขาอยากให้เรา
เข้าไปแล้วก็ซื้อสวิทซ์สมุนใส่
โอเคเข้าใจแล้วครับอ่ะเดี๋ยวพาไปเที่ยว
ที่ที่เป็นธรรมชาติบ้างไม่เอาห่าถ้าไปที่
ปราจีนบุรี
คนส่วนใหญ่ก็จะคิดถึงที่นี่ครับคู่เอกคิด
ถึงที่ไหน
ปราจีนบุรีหรอไม่เคยไปอ่ะพี่ก็คิดถึงที่
นี่ชื่ออะไรนะเห็นไหมเห็นมะมาฮ่าๆได้ยิน
เพื่อนบอกมีเพื่อนเพื่อนที่เคยทำงานด้วย
กันเราว่างปราจีนไฟปราจีนแล้วก็ไปปราจีน
แล้วไม่ได้ล่องแก่งก็เหมือนว่าไปไม่ถึง
ประจีนบุรีๆวันที่แถวคิดถึงในตัวเองคิด
ถึงสวนทุเรียนปราจีนๆๆที่ปาร์ตี้ผู้หญิง
มีทุเรียนตอนนี้นะคะเขาเพิ่งไปปลูกเนาะ
เมื่อก่อนไม่มีนะคะภายทรายอีกไม่เกิน 20
30 ปีเนาะใกล้กับเวลากูอ่ะเด็กๆไม่มีนะ
คะแต่ว่าผู้ใหญ่โตมาแล้วนะมีสวนทุเรียน
ล็อคแก่งหน้าชื่อว่าแก่งอิ่มเพิ้งโอเคเอ้
าที่พี่นี่นี้น่าสนใจค่ะนักเรียน
ควรติ๊กเข้าไปลองมาแล้วอายุนั้นแล้วครับ
สนุกมากเลยๆหาเขาบีบเขามีคนขัดท้ายให้
หน่อยเลยแล้วทำ 2 คนมีคนที่อยู่ข้างหน้า 1
คนแล้วก็คนข้างหลังอีก 1 คนส่วนตรงกลาง
คือเราคือพวกเราถ้าไปกันหลายๆคนก็สนุกได้
นะไปกัน 5 คน
8 คนก็ได้ค่ะ
คุยชอบล่องแก่งมากลองแกงสนุกเต้นได้ที่
ไหนได้ตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นแต่แต่ห้ามดื้อนะ
คะต้องฟังฝันให้คนผู้ขายโอนคนที่เป็นหัว
เรือกับท้ายเรือเค้าจะบอกว่าโอเคช่วยพาย
ไปทางนี้หายไปถึงนี้เพราะว่าอ้ะนักเรียน
อาจจะงงว่าล่องแก่งคืออะไรแกะไงแต่งมันจะ
เป็นลำธารที่อยู่
ในภูเขาแล้วก็มีก้อนหิน
ถ้ามีก้อนหินเราจะเรียกว่าเป็นแสงเป็นแม่
น้ำนั่นแหละแล้วมันจะมีหินอยู่ในแม่น้ำ
หน้าแบบนี้ไงก็จะได้ก็เป็นแก่งเวลาที่ลบ
ใครพายเรือมาใกล้ๆเราก็ต้องพายออกอยากให้
ไปชนกับหินตรงนี้โหมันตื่นเต้นตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมคะใช่ครับต้องระวังทั้งหมดมันหลบต้อง
หลบให้สนุกมาก
กู Arty ร้องแกะเนี่ยอ่าสามารถขับรถไป
แล้วก็ไปซื้อทัวร์ล่องแก่งได้เลยนะคะได้
ได้เลยครับได้เลยหรือนะครับคิดเป็นคนใช่
ไหมคะเขาคิดเป็นเป็นรำ
เขาคิดเป็นคนนั้นเป็นคนแต่ถ้าไปกันหลายๆ
คนไปเป็นกลุ่มเขาก็จะคิดก็คิดเป็นห่วง
เหมือนกันนะคิดเป็นคนเหมือนกันคิดเป็นคน
ใช่ๆ
แต่ลำหนึ่งน่าจะลงได้ประมาณ 4 คนน่าใช้
ครับมีลำเล็กลำใหญ่มี 8 คนก็มี 5 คนหรือ 4
คนก็ได้ได้ครับ
เป็นเรืออย่างเนาะที่นั่งแล้วเป็นเรือยาง
ต้องใส่หมวกกันน็อคนะคะแล้วก็สีส้มๆที่
เขาใส่คืออะไรคะอ้านี่เป็นเสื้อคนไทย
เรียกเสื้อชูชีพค่ะอาเสื้อสูทเสื้อชูชีพ
ก็คือทำให้เราตกน้ำแล้วก็ไม่จมน้ำค่ะไหน
ครับทุกคนคล่องใส่แก่งหินเพลิงอันตรายมาก
ไหมมี
แกงเป็ดโรไหนถ้าไปช่วงที่น้ำเยอะน้ำเยอะ
ก็จะอันตรายมากกว่าน้ำปากน้ำป่าบาง thin
น้ำตามก็จะแรงใช่ไหมครับช่วงหน้าฝนแล้วก็
จะไม่ค่อยไปก็จะรอให้ฝนฝนหยุดไปแล้วสัก
ระยะนึงน้ำก็จะค่อยๆลดหนูค่ายเพราะว่า
เวลาล่องแก่งเขาจะมีเลเวลนะคะนักเรียนได้
ใช่ๆเบสิค basic  Level หนึ่ง Level  2
Level  3  Level  4  Level
555 ถึงน่าจะ 5-6 เนี่ยถ่างตารายานๆของ
น่าจะเร็วเอวประมาณ 3-4  3-4 ครับมา
ขวดอีกชอบครัวตี้ชอบตอนที่พายไปแล้วตอน
ที่ใกล้ๆจะถึงใกล้ๆจะถึงเขาจะให้ทุกคนน่ะ
ลงจากเรือเอ้าทำไมอ่ะลอยตัวไปตามน้ำอาร์
โอใช่ครับทุกคนสามารถเล่นก็ได้ลอยไปตาม
น้ำแต่น้ำก็จะไหลเร็วมากนะครับอ่ะแล้วแต่
เรามีชูชีพไงใช่มีชีวิตชีพอ่ะสนุกมากครับ
คนที่จะไปเล่นไปล่องแก่งเนี่ยต้องเตรียม
ตัวเลยว่าจะต้องเปียกแน่นอนเปียกน้ำแน่
นอนกล้องถ่ายรูปไม่ต้องเอาไปเชื่อฮ่าๆๆ
ฮ่าอ้าวเป็นกล้องถ่ายรูปที่เปียกน้ำได้ก็
เอาไปได้ครับโทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์หาโทรศัพท์
ไม่แนะนำครับนำออฟฟิศเอาไปก็ต้องมี
อุปกรณ์ที่ใส่ที่ป้องกันป้องกันเวลาตบน้ำ
ได้ใช่ครับ
หรือไม่ก็ต้องมีอะไรเป็นโทรศัพท์ที่โดน
น้ำได้ลงได้นะคะ
เราก็อาจจะไม่ได้มีไม่มีเวลาที่จะถ่าย
เยอะเพราะเราจะต้อง
ไปถ่ายรูปอย่างเดียวได้ไหมคะให้ให้เข้า
ข่ายแล้วเราถ่ายรูปอ่ะมีแต่ถ้าเราไม่
ระวังเราก็อาจจะตกจากเรือได้ๆๆต้องนั่ง
ให้ระมัดระวังขายคู๋เคยไปล่องแก่งแต่ไม่
ใช่ที่นี่แต่ว่าแต่ว่าก็คือเอากล้องถ่าย
รูปไปสุดท้ายกล้องเนี่ยไม่ได้ใช้ค่ะฝนตก
ต้องเข้าจะมีผังถังแล้วก็เอากล้องใส่แล้ว
ก็ปิดเรื่อง
ตลกมากเกือบพัง
แต่ถ้าไปล่องแก่งที่เป็นเลเวลต่ำ level1
level2 ก็ก็น่าจะมีเวลามีโอกาสที่แบบ
สบายๆถ่ายรูปเล่นได้อะไรอะเพราะว่าแบบนี้
น้ำมันจะมันจะโยกตลอดได้ใช่กับๆไปครับ
สนุกสนุกตรงที่มันโยกตลอดนี่แหละครับ
โอเคอ่าเหนื่อยกันแล้วใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวพาไป
อีกที่หนึ่ง
จบไปหลายที่แล้วอะเดี๋ยวพาไปดูหลังได้อีก
เอาที่เหนื่อยแล้วใช่ไหมพายเรือเหนื่อย
และเดี๋ยวถ้าเราไปพักผ่อนสบายๆบ้างครับไป
ที่นี่ครับไปดูไปดูอือแมลงตัวนึง
เอออ๋อ
เป็นแมลง
ดาวเลยมันน่า
แมลงที่มีแสงไฟอยู่อยู่ด้านท้ายน่ะคนไทย
เรียกว่าเรียกตัวอะไรนะครับกูอยากรู้จัก
เดี๋ยวนั้น King ห้อยชาติใช่ครับหิ่งห้อย
หน้าที่นี่ครับที่นี่จะอยู่ในกรมทหารปืน
ใหญ่
นะครับใช่ครับเป็นพื้นที่ของทหารว่าที่
นี่เนี่ยที่นี่เนี่ยมีหิ่งห้อยเยอะเขาก็
เปิดเปิดให้คนเข้าไปดูหิ่งห้อยได้ต้องมี
ทุกวันเลยหิงห้อย ami ไม่ทุกวันครับจะ
เป็นเหรอช่วงประมาณเดือนช่วงหน้าฝนครับ
เดือนมิถุนายนถึงเดือนกรกฎาคมค่ะใช่ครับ
ก็เวลาที่ไปดูก็ว่ามัน
6:30 นข่าวโมงครึ่งถึงประมาณ 20:00 นก็
จะเห็น
น้าๆกับตัวหิงห้อยก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ครับ
แสงไฟ 4 แสงแสงสีนี้เลยใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับสี
นี้เลยครับที่ก้นของหิ่งห้อยก็จะมีไฟนี่
ไฟอยู่ตรงนี่ขายจะส่องแสงออกมาแล้วก็บิน
แล้วหรอแจงเข้าใจเหมือนกับสว่างดับทราย
ใต้ๆ
แบบนี้ไปใต้ใหญ่ในคิดถึงผีเลยป่ะฮ่าๆๆ
ขอกินไฟตัวนิดเดียวใช้ใจใส่อีกค่อยจะตัว
นิดเดียวอ่าแต่เวลาที่อยู่กันเยอะก็จะสวย
ก็มากๆระยิบระยับน้าโอเคเยอะเลยมากเลย
เห็นค่อยเนี่ยจ่าย
เขาจะบินไปบินมาออกไม่ใช่นี้ใช่ไหมค่ะจะ
มีบาลจังหวัดสบายจังวะไม่เขาทวงหิงห้อยขอ
ไปดูแล้วก็แล้วก็มีเรือแพงด้วยนะอ๋อพ่อ
ร้อยไม่รู้อ่ะตอนกลางคืนน่ะเราก็มันจะ
กุ๊กกุ๊กแล้วอยู่ที่เดิมเอ๊ะทำไมใหญ่จัง
เลย
เฮ็ดก้อยปลอมด้วยออกกลางวันผ่านเป็นไฟ
อ่ะไปพันเอาไว้เป็นไฟที่เปิดเป็นเปิดเฟส
อ่ะเพราะว่าเคยเห็นหิ่งห้อยจะเข้าใจไงอ๋อ
จะไม่เหมือนกันส่งที่เค้าจะเป็นชายใน
แต่ถ้าอยู่กับที่แล้ว
ใช่หรือเปล่าใช่ของจริงหรือเปล่าอ่ะก็
ต้องดูดีๆถ้าเราชอบไปดูเองค่อย
สวยนะคะสวยนี่อะไรอีกครั้ง 555 เดี๋ยวนะ
มีเวลาอีกนิดหน่อยเดี๋ยวพาไปที่นี่ครับ
5 น้ำตกไนแองการ่าอ่ะคะตัวนี้อ่าไม่มี
ใหญ่เหมือนไนแองการ่านะครับแต่ว่ามีตัว
นี้ชื่อน้ำตกอ่าเดี๋ยวนะน้ำตกคลองเพกานะ
ครับใช่ครับที่อยู่ติดกับอ่ะอุทยานแห่ง
ชาติเขาใหญ่ติดกับนครราชสีมา
อ่ะแล้วที่ที่ที่เราร้องแก่งน่ะครับมาที่
น้ำตกมั้ยฮะ
อยู่ห่างกันอยู่ห่างกันนิดนึงได้ครับแต่
ว่าถ้าลองเก่งแล้วมาเรื่อยๆจะเจอน้ำตก
มั้ยถ้าไม่เจออีกแล้วแม่น้ำไปกับคนละแม่
น้ำ
ผู้เอกกูบอกว่าโวจะต้องแกร่งมาแล้วตกลงมา
อย่างนี้เฮ้ยไม่มีเขาไม่มี
คือชอบร้องแก่งนะเราไม่ชอบร่องแก่ถ้าตกลง
ผมคิดว่าถ้ามีถ้ามีตกลงมาจากตรงนี้น่าจะ
มีคนมาเล่นเยอะนะครับเอาหรอคนมีคนคงมีคน
อยากมาเป็นถนนน้ำตกสูงประมาณกี่เมตรหน้า
เดี๋ยวนะตัวนี้อ่านที่น้ำตกอันนี้เนี่ย
ความสูงฉันอาจประมาณ 10 เมตรหนูเข้าสู่นะ
เนี่ย 5 ประมาณ 10 เมตรสูงมากกว่าตี้คู๋
เม็ดเดียวไม่ขึ้นเมตรก็น่าจะ 2 ชั้นบ้าน
ชั้น 1 บ้านชั้นหนึ่งก็ประมาณ 3 เมตรใช่
ไหม 10 เมตรก็สามชั้น 3 ชั้น 533 นั้น
โอเคตกปลาไม่ตายแคบลงมาให้ลงมาในน้ำ
ๆแต่น้ำตกอันนี้เอาเวลาไปเนี่ยเราต้อง
เดินขึ้นไปนะครับหาเดินขึ้นใหม่นิดหน่อย
ประมาณ 3  3-5 กิโลกรัม
ก็เลือดขึ้นไปนะคือรถอยู่ข้างล่างของน้ำ
ตกนึกถึงข้างบนของน้ำตกหน้าอยู่ข้างล่าง
ครับอยู่ข้างล่างพรุ่งนี้หมดน่าจะอันตราย
เนาะตายข้างบนอันตรายไม่ให้ขึ้นไป
ครับโอเคอ่าที่สุดท้ายครับอะไรนะครับไป
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะอ่าที่นี่ครัวตี้ยังไม่เคย
ไปไงไม่เคยแวะเข้าไปเขาหน้าถ้ามีโอกาส
เดี๋ยวจะไป
ที่ไม่ไปเพราะว่าต้องเดินต้องเคยดิ 315
กินขี้เกียจเด้อไปไปเอ่อลายเรือแล้ว
เหนื่อยแล้วเดินไม่ไหวแล้ว
ต้องเลือกนะคะแล้วแกจะไปน้ำตกหรือไปลอง
แก่ง
สลบ
โอเคมีอีกใช่ไหมคะที่สุดท้ายเดี๋ยวพาไป
ที่วัดครับหลักไม่ไหว้พระก่อนไปไหว้พระ
ก่อนครับอ่า
ที่วัดนี้เนี่ยชื่อวัดต้นโพธิ์ศรีก็เพราะ
ว่าหมี่ต้นโพธิ์ต้นที่อายุ
อาจเรียกว่าอยู่ในเก่าแก่คณะนานนานที่สุด
ในประเทศไทยอยู่ที่นี่นับกี่ปีคะ
อาเขาเขาบอกว่าเขาบอกว่าต้นโพธิ์ต้นนี้มา
จากประเทศอินเดียค่ะคนเดียวกันกับที่พระ
พุทธเจ้าตรัสรู้
อ่ะ
ศรีมหาโพธิ์ต้นศรีมหาโพธิ์ใช้ครับ 5 เขา
บอกว่ามาตั้งแต่ประมาณสองพันปีที่แล้ว
ต้นนี้นะครับโอ้โห
เขาก็เลยบอกว่าต้นโพธิ์ต้นเนี้ยอ่าเป็น
ต้นโพธิ์ที่อายุมากที่สุดในประเทศไทยจะ
ต้นโพธิ์อายุยืนนะคุณไม่ตัดนะคะนักเรียน
หรือไม่ตัดเนี่ยเขาก็ไม่ตายถ้าเขาจะต่าง
ถูกฟ้าผ่าแต่ว่าฟ้าผ่าเขาก็ไม่ตายนะคะเขา
ก็ลากเค้าก็ล้านเขาก็ไปแล้วก็ถ้ามีลากไป
ขึ้นต่ออีกที่อื่นได้นะไปๆบริเวณนั้นใช่
ก็จะถามว่า 2,000 ปีก็เชื่อได้นะมีโอกาส
ใช่ไหมครับมีโชคขนาดเป็นไปได้ใช่มั้ยมาย
คู๋ชอบต้นโพธิ์ล่ะครับใบโพธิ์สวยกลัวตี
ชอบใบโพธิ์ใบโพธิ์จะเป็นทรง V หัวใจอ้า
ใช่ครับเป็นตรงหัวใจแบบนี้
เหมือนในกุฏิวาดพยายามอาหารที่เหมือน
ขวดตีต้องอยู่ใต้ต้นโพธิ์เวลาที่ใบโพธิ์
ใหญ่ๆหรือสีเหลืองก็ได้สีเขียวข้างล่าง
อย่างนี้พัดเวลาก็ใบโพธิ์เขาตีกันน่ะอ๋อ
อะไรครับเสียงเพราะนะคะ
แล้วก็ฟังไม่มีอะไรทำเหรอคะนั่งฝันนั่ง
ฟังเสียงลมพัดใบโพธิ์ที่ออฟฟิศเก่ามีแต่
ว่าขอโทษมาก่อนนะคะเขามีต้นโพธิ์ใหญ่แล้ว
ก็ไปยืนแล้วก็ฟังเสียงเสียงใหม่โผล่อ๋อก็
มีพี่ๆแขนงอื่นก็ถามว่าครูเอไม่ทำงานหรอ
โอเคฟังฟัง Learn  Learn ไปหน่อยใช่ไหม
ครับนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอ้าวันนี้คุณอาจตีก็พาไปเที่ยว
ปราจีนบุรีใช่ครับมีโอกาสเท่านั้นมีโอกาส
มาประเทศไทยก็ลองไปเพราะว่าอยู่ใกล้
กรุงเทพครับขับรถไปแป๊บเดียวนะครับใน
ครั้งโอเคครับแล้วเดี๋ยวคลิปหน้าเรากลับ
มาเจอกันใหม่นะครับกลัวตี้แล้วครูพี่เอ๋
จะพาไปเที่ยวที่ไหนเดี๋ยวค่อยติดตามกัน
คราวนะครับเก็บนี้ถ้าไปก่อนครับขายค่ะ
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋ดีค่ะนักเรียนภาย
ม.ค